you've been in
journalism I did not know this detail
tell me if I'm getting this accurately
that in Nashville not only were you the
first uh black anchor but the youngest
19 I mean that's
incredible
yeah and when we first met I was really
young yeah it means so much to me
because when I was 14 and I had that
conversation with you not only looking
back but I could tell at the time that
you had so much wisdom about you know
and maybe it was while you were learning
these things yeah I was going to say I
didn't have the wisdom then looking at
that I didn't have the wisdom but I did
pay attention you know just as I mean
the audience was a serious thing for me
and I did pay attention I did listen to
the audience and I did feel like
I was the representative for all of you
but that was my greatest you know I I
never have been to therapy that's what I
was talk about with you you never went
to therapy but the show but I had all my
therapy on the show in front of
everybody and you know when I first
started in
1986 with the national show nobody was
going to therapy even speaking about
therapy on television was like taboo
taboo nobody nobody even and now
everybody has gone to therapy so I did
my therapy in front of exposed to
everyone at a time when people were
still just adjusting their own
Consciousness to the idea of accepting
somebody else being able to counsel you
about your life I just I always love
them see things differently that you
know coming on on your meeting you for
the first time when I was 14 and it's
funny cuz I'm happy to tell you now that
I don't think and feel any of those
things about myself
yeah I feel
like I'm learning more here not playing
a character but being myself my
children's Mother my friend's
friend but the show is a study in human
behavior you get yes yes yes the show is
a study in human behavior and you made
that okay for everyone I think part of
why self-work is a national discussion
springboard from you and there is one
thing there is one thing that I'm so
attached to you got it do you remember
when you gave this you yes okay so Oprah
gave me this blanket 10 years ago over
10 years ago and I've never not SLE with
it I dry clean it okay I treat this like
the most important thing in my life you
envelop me every single night of my life
this I am attached to and I don't care
well thank you because you know what I
love a beautiful blanket it's my most
important thing ever thank you um will
you uh to close out our hang session
play a little game with
[Music]
me